هذا هو المكان الذي اغتيل فيه لاستاذ
الجامعي عقيل عبد الله من قبل المسلحين
يستقلون دراجه ناريه وهو على مقربه من
منزله ليفارق الحياه بعد نقله الى
المستشفى
مجلس العزاء كسر حزنه التاهب الكبير
للقوات الامنيه والقاء القبض على الجنات
نتقدم بالشكر الجزيل الى قياده الشرطه ذي
قار والاجهزه الاستخباريه جميعا لجهودها
المبذوله وملاحقه الجنات والقبض عليهم
الاوساط التعليميه مع زميلهم ما استنكرت
ما حدث وحولت المصابه الى تظاهرات تطالب
بالقصاص من القتله وانهاء ظاهره السلاح
المنفلد الذي يستهدف كفاءات العراق
ان قتل دوله اثنين القتلوا اخونا
وعمر
نا
ابدا فاحنا نطالبهم بالقصاص الالهي قصاص
اول مره حكم الله وثانيا حكم القانون
القانون العراقي يؤكد هذا الشيء 460 القتل
المتعمد هو مو يعني فوضى يعني حتى
الحيوانات عندها بعض الفكر وبعد النظام
القوات الامنيه نجحت في القبض على
المتهمين بجريمه في وقت قصير سرعه تحرك
القوات الحكوميه ابقت على الامن والهدوء
الذي عاشته المحافظه منذ شهور دون ان تشوه
صورته هذه الحادثه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
شاكر عواد الناصريه